and so like basically the more partners  a woman has the less likely she is to  have a happy marriage so if someone has  a bad boy passed like she's less likely  to be satisfied in her marriage because  if you're a virgin when you get married  you have an 80 chance of getting into a  happy marriage after 10 years if you  have had sex with more than five people  which i think most men pray for nowadays  and  um  it drops down to 25  okay and so i think that's why  historically we've always protected  women and like tell them to like not be  sexual outside of marriage because the  bond like the bond is so strong for  women during sex we release a hormone  during sex that men don't